I deserved better I did nothing that was
causing the former director of Nevada
prisons is breaking his silence after
what he calls his forced resignation I
was released unfairly after the
high-profile Escape of a convicted
murderer Charles Daniels stepped down at
the request of Governor Steve sisilak on
September 30th he held this press
conference four days before election day
unfortunately a false narrative
previously communicated by the governor
and his staff enabled egregious
statements to be published statement
statements which have defamed me and
eviscerated my faithful and
distinguished career of Public Service
on both state and National levels what
about the election being a few days away
though the elections of no consequence
to me the governor's office says Daniels
threatened to speak publicly if the
state wouldn't pay him a million dollars
a request in this letter obtained by the
8 news now investigators are you
concerned it could be seen as extortion
that's not my concern this is about me
because you have to understand my
reputation has been destroyed the Escape
of the convicted murderer happened under
your leadership though correct what
would you say about that so if you want
to say yes you are the director what
would I say yes I was the director but I
will tell you this I literally begged
for the resources Daniel's attorney
writes he was retained to pursue age and
racial employment discrimination claims
against the state since he was dismissed
as a political sacrifice to divert
attention away from Governor CIS elect's
struggling re-election campaign do you
think racism is at play here all of that
information will come out and I think
that it's uh it's important that
I'm
regulated and what I say now Daniels
claims an attorney and Governor sis
elect's office wanted him to change the
timeline of events surrounding the
prisoner's Escape he refused and filed a
whistleblower complaint his attorney
says they filed a complaint with the
equal employment opportunity commission
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now